thank everybody for uh being here today
I am joined by members of the Texas
legislature and we are here to explain
to
America that we are dealing with the
biggest border crisis since America had
borders it's all because Joe Biden
allowed this entire area to be
penetrated by the drug cartels that
smuggled in illegal immigrants and if
you see an area that is boxed off by a
container that has razor wire on the
container or on the ground or on the
fence those are areas that illegal
immigrants were once able to cross that
are now unable to cross and the reason
why we've been able to achieve that
level of decrease in ille illegal
Crossings is only because of great
teamwork in agencies across the state of
Texas first an update about some numbers
from the Texas Department of Public
Safety they have made over
39,000 criminal arrests they have uh uh
apprehended more than 480,000 illegal
migrants they have deterred more than
95,000 illegal entries and engaged in
more than 4,300
bailouts they have filed more than
19,000 charges for smuggling those
charges for smuggling now face a new
consequence because of members of the
legislature who stand behind me they
passed a bill that I signed into law
that increases the mandatory minimum
time behind bars for Smugglers to 10
years if you smuggle somebody into or
through and across the state of Texas
illegally you'll be spending a long time
behind
bars in addition to what the Texas
Department of Public Safety has been
doing doing we've also had unprecedented
success by the Texas National Guard uh
they have more than a million encounters
with illegal immigrants uh they have
turned back more than 990,000 people who
were trying to get into the country
illegally in addition to what they're
doing uh through other agencies and in
part through what the National Guard
themselves are doing uh there have been
more than uh 160 Mi altogether of
barriers placed up not counting the
border wall uh they include the the
razor wire uh fencing anti-climb
barriers these conx boxes and the buoys
uh that are in the river those together
add up to more than 160 Mi of barriers
that have been placed up also Texas is
the first and only state in the history
of the United States of America to build
our own border wall
we if you look at the amount of wall
already constructed and uh the amount of
wall that is going to be under
construction Texas will have built more
of the Trump border wall than even Trump
built in the state of Texas now the the
the
results are amazing if if you look at
what has changed with regard to Illegal
border crossings in the past half year
or so you see that even though Texas
represents about 2/3 of the Border we
represent only about 30% of The
Crossings the the lead Crossing areas
are California Arizona and New Mexico
that represent 70% of The Crossings now
unlike before migrants are choosing to
go to States other than Texas and that's
because Texas has put up the resistance
that it has early on under to the Biden
Administration most of the migrants were
coming through Texas that's not true the
same is true for this area that We
Gather in right now if you look at this
uh massive Park area this is an area
where you would regularly see 2,000
3,000 maybe 4,000 people crossing the
border illegally since this park has
been taken over by the National Guard
the daily average is under 10 a day it
shows that deterrence can achieve
results at decreasing illegal
immigration the only reason why it's not
happening is because the president of
the United States is not enforcing the
laws that are already on the books he
does not need more laws he has the tools
in his toolbox to do exactly what Texas
is doing and that's to deny illegal
entry into the country which he is
required to do by laws already passed by
Congress part of the teamwork
that we're seeing is is tremendous
leadership by the Texas National Guard
uh to look forward about where we are
going uh on strategies to both add and
to accommodate more National Guard in
this area we will also work with the
National Guard to continue their
strategies of adding more miles of
Raisor wire and anti-climb barrier to
also recognize another branch of
government in Texas uh that is a partner
in this effort and that's the
legislative branch the tools and
strategies that DPS the National Guard
that I and others have are to do
anything to secure the Border would not
exist if it weren't for the efforts of
uh the members of the Texas House of
Representatives I want to have some of
them speak at this time in including uh
the chair of House
Appropriations chairman Greg bonnet
thank you governor governor thank you
for your leadership on this issue I
remember in uh mid 2021 the governor
asked to visit with me in his office he
had already initiated operation lonar
and what he shared in that visit was
that the problem at the border was of a
magnitude that we had never before
experienced and efforts and initiatives
we had taken in the past were simply
going to be insufficient we needed a new
plan and it was going to require great
resources and since that moment with
Governor Abbott's leadership and with
speaker felin's leadership lieutenant
governor Patrick and all of the members
of the House Representatives that you
see here we have been unwavering in our
commitment to step into the Gap and to
address a chaotic crisis where the
federal government has refused to
address and enforce our immigration laws
when you look at the Appropriations for
border security under the four years of
the Trump Administration in Texas that
was $1.6 billion
for the four years of the Biden
presidency Texas is appropriating
11.6 billion dollars to do the same
thing and what we're seeing is that that
deterrence does work and the park in
which you're standing right now is proof
positive of where once there was chaos
and several thousand people a day coming
across it has flowed to an almost
non-existent number so it can be done
when you break down the effort about
$3.1 billion dollar goes into barriers
and Border infrastructure about $200
million because Texas has banned
Sanctuary cities in our state goes to
transporting illegal immigrants to
Sanctuary cities in other parts of the
United States and the balance is spent
on the Texas Military Department and the
Department of Public Safety for human
resources and operations and we thank
them for the great work that they are
doing
and the thing that everybody should
understand is that the governor the
speaker lieutenant governor and all of
the members who you see before you stand
firmly committed that as long as there
is an absence of the federal government
doing its job to secure our
international border we will step up and
take their place thank you very much uh
next is representative
Spiller yes
on Texans know uh that the B
Administration has completely failed and
refused to secure our border and enforce
Federal immigration policy our cries for
help our demands for help have been
ignored we've had enough in Texas and so
uh with my help we I carried and we with
the group here today uh passed and with
Governor Abbott's uh uh signature passed
SB for the strongest border security
bill in the history of our state and the
history of our nation for the first time
ever uh we're allowed to prosecute
people coming into our our state
illegally from a foreign Nation if they
cross at someplace other than a lawful
Port of Entry it's a landmark bill that
allows Texans to protect Texas uh to
allows us to return those that arrive
here illegally and to prosecute and
incarcerate those that refuse to comply
and so U it's completely constitutional
because it's not it's in compliance with
the uh president set in the Arizona case
uh it's not preempted by existing
Federal immigration law it's not in
conflict with Federal immigration law
that's in in place and mostly uh Texas
has the right the constitutional right
and Authority uh to secure its border
and so uh we're proud of that bill the B
Administration continues uh uh to fight
us uh they're spending more effort to
fight us than they are to secure the
border and uh we look forward to that
fight uh in the court I know his
Department of Justice uh has uh has
filed a suit to uh to contest that uh to
that I would say bring it we're ready
for that fight and so uh uh I would look
forward to continue with the uh
opportunity to work uh with this group
of conservative Representatives uh to
continue to protect Texas and our
country look forward to uh working with
Governor Abbott uh and his leadership we
thank him for that and the job that he's
done so that Texas leads the way to show
others how we protect our state and our
country thank you representative and now
representative tric Clair
every single legislator standing here
represents a border District because
every one of our districts is impacted
by what comes across this border every
state in our country is a border state
because there is no state in the United
States that is not impacted by the drugs
by the weapons and by the humans that
are trafficked across this
border Americans American children are
dying every day of fentanyl in every
single state that comes across this
border women who are being trafficked
across this border are sold into sex
slavery every day and trafficked through
the cartel Network across our country
and let me make one thing very clear
there is not a single person coming
across that is free every single one of
them is paying a very dear price to the
cartel they are paying with their money
are paying with their bodies and they
are pay paying by being sold into
indentured servitude and President Biden
is not just supporting it he is
encouraging it instead of protecting
Americans he is protecting the cartels
they are making more money off of his
failure at the border than they ever
have before and Governor Abbott and the
Texas legislature are stepping into that
Gap and let me tell you we will not give
up Texans are no stranger to being put
under pressure to having to stand up for
what we believe in and this is our
moment Governor Abbott is supported by
Republican Governors from across this
country many of whom are sending troops
here to help us the real heroes are the
DPS officers in the Texas National Guard
who are serving every day away from
their families to make sure that Texans
and every American are safe and the
legislators behind me are ready to give
the governor the tools and the resources
and the funding that he needs to keep
this fight going this is the number one
issue not just to my district not just
to this state but to Americans across
the country and so to every American out
there Texas has your back Governor
Abbott has your back and Governor Abbott
is doing the job that president Biden
refuses to do and we will never give up
thank you so much thank you very much
and a big thank you to all these members
of the Texas legislature uh Texas would
not be in a position to do what we're
doing uh without them and and the laws
they passed the efforts they've
undertaken and so I thank all of you all
very much for what you've done uh for
being here and what we will continue to
do with that we'll take a few
questions
uh the the press that we were sent you
talk about a an announcement what what
was the announcement have we we already
heard that announcement or is there
something else that you would like to
add to I mean the importance of you with
Dev well for for one uh the importance
of the people who join me today is the
fact is the wire that you see preventing
illegal entry the conx boxes that you
see uh the soldiers that you see the
Texas Department of Public Safety that
you see none of that would be here but
for the people who stand with me today
as far as future announcements listen we
are we being my office we're working
with the Texas National Guard uh on
strategies to to to make sure uh that
we're going to to find ways that we will
be able to both add and accommodate uh
more soldiers being deployed in this
area
and more more more more details will be
provided in the future at what point at
what point govern would you be willing I
mean you're a Christian person a lot of
people in you know even Democrats are
Christians something like that so
without going too deep into
religion will be a there will be a
moment where you'll be willing to sit
down and have a conversation at least
with the opposite side as to you meet me
here I'll meet you there is there a is
there a possibility of that so let's be
clear about two things one is I've
attempted that uh I have provided uh
eight letters to President Biden and his
administration uh asking for certain
actions I've received exactly zero
response one of those letters I handed
to him personally to his hand it was a
single page it was not complicated and
explained exactly what needed to be done
in order to secure the border at that
same meeting I handed the exact same
letter to secretary me orcus who said
that he would work with us and of course
he has not so the bid Administration has
done nothing to work with us despite me
reaching out on eight different times
that said there is a key factor that we
insist on and that is the beginning of
our discussions starts with the
enforcement of the rule of law there are
laws on the books as we speak right now
that don't need to be added that don't
need to be changed that do two things
it denies illegal entry into the United
States of America and it requires the
president the executive branch to detain
them if they do get in illegally those
two laws are not being followed
negotiations begin once the bid
Administration starts to enforcing the
laws any I'll get you both govern is
there any now from the state of Texas to
expand simar operations here in Shelby
Park I know you are counting the success
in the pluming of the legal process are
any plans right now to operations
officials will control certain parts of
the border right now so yes we are
working on expansion plans uh to expand
uh the successful operations that we've
seen in certain locations uh that deter
illegal immigration uh and uh some of
those will be announced after they occur
uh others will be announced beforehand
but just know this and that is the
National Guard is relentless on a daily
basis they're adding more razor wire
barrier more antil barrier more other
ways to repel people from trying to
enter illegally and I got to emphasize
this and that is in doing so there's
actually been a dramatic reduction in
drownings in the river by more than 50%
if if if people are enticed to cross a
treacherous River uh they will cross
that River and some will lose their
lives one thing we know for a fact right
behind you is a bridge that people are
walking across as we speak no one drowns
on a bridge no one gets cut by razor
wire on a bridge if people tried to
enter the country through the pathway
created by Congress as the pathway into
the country lives would be saved and
with the the B Adra right now isting the
decision whether to pursue legal action
regarding the operations here in Shelby
Park whe the B Administration pursues IL
legal action would that affect any
decision made by so I I actually hope
the Biden Administration takes legal
action about this area because I want to
make one thing perfectly clear one
reason why this area is occupied by the
state of Texas is to prevent the bid
Administration from any further
violation of federal law on this Texas
land they are violating two laws
required by Congress Congress requires
the federal government to deny illegal
entry they the F the Biden
Administration use this park to Aid
illegal entry into our country and then
secondly you saw the masses the
thousands that they allowed together in
this part for processing and then to be
sent elsewhere in the United States
that's Mass parole Congress has
specifically prohibited Mass parole into
the United States what Texas is doing
right now is we are the ones actually
enforcing laws passed by Congress Biden
is breaking those laws and we look
forward to our day in court where we are
able to tell America the way that Joe
Biden is violating the laws that are on
the books by Congress right now two more
questions two more questions sh I get
heard I'm I told her I'd come to her
I'll come back to you here in a second
we heard conerns
people
so on in in that gang in particular I
don't have information about that and I
know that DPS would be able to get you
that answer specifically however I do
want to tell you this uh we know that uh
DPS uh is arresting dangerous gang
members all the time including they they
arrested a MS-13 gang member who uh was
on the terrorist watch list and we know
that there are terrorists and people on
the terrorist watch list who seek to
across the border all the time under Joe
Biden's tenure there's been an all-time
record number of people on the Terrace
watch list who were apprehended but
here's the key fact if you're on the
terrrace watch list they going to pay
extra money to the cartels to not be
apprehended what Joe Biden does not know
what the FBI does not know is the number
of people on the Terrace watch list who
were able to evade detection enter the
United States illegally and are are
moving around the country with the
potential to cause catastrophic
harm so the the the next steps uh is to
uh I'm I'm working with the National
Guard on plans as we speak right now uh
to expand the National Guard effort
along the border region uh we're going
to work on strategies to uh ensure the
capabilities of the of the National
Guard to uh add uh more soldiers more
resources more capabilities so they can
be even more
successful thank you so thank you
all
you want with that or this
uh there we go here we
go appreciate you yes sir thank you
we'll see you this weekend sounds good
Governor thank you we appreciate you
very
much thank
you